- So Grace, is there anything
that I can proactively do,
to protect my accounts?
- Absolutely. I'm so glad you asked.
We recommend that folks use something
called two-step verification.
Now you have a password
to log into your account.
But if you are able to turn
on two-step verification,
that is a second layer of authentication
to verify that you are you.
This is extremely helpful in the event
that a password is stolen
through a phishing attempt
because even if someone has
access to your password,
they won't be able to
log into your account
without also having your
phone, or your computer,
which is far less likely.
So, two-step verification can mean
receiving a text message
to verify that it's you,
or an email, or even a phone call.
This is something we
really recommend people do,
especially for things like bank accounts,
or any sort of account
where you have a lot of
personal information.
- No, I can't tell you how
important that is, Grace.
I use two-step verification
on pretty much any account
that I definitely do not
want people to break into.
And I have to say, over the
last four or five years,
there's been a few situations
where all of a sudden,
I got a text message on my phone saying,
"Here's your security code."
And I'm like, "Wait, I didn't
even ask for a security code."
It means someone might have
compromised one of my accounts,
and is trying to log in.
But the two-step verification
is actually keeping them out.
Because the odds that someone
got your password somehow,
and has physical possession of your phone,
or a computer, very, very low,
unless you have some shady
people in your house,
or your workplace.
- That's absolutely right, Sal.
And the fact that you
received that message
and immediately said,
"Hey, this wasn't me."
That's two step verification
working as intended.
Another tool that I like to
recommend that folks use,
is something called the password manager.
This can help you keep
track of your passwords,
and make sure that you're
using strong passwords,
and updating them regularly.
So you can save your
passwords in your browser.
So, instead of having to keep track
of 20 different passwords yourself,
that tool does it for you.
- No, that's really helpful.
Because I think there can
be a strong temptation
to put easy passwords, or
reuse the same password
over and over again, to
just make it memorable.
But that makes you extra vulnerable.
So if you use these things,
you can have super secure,
different passwords
for every site.
- Exactly.
Unfortunately many people
do reuse the same password,
or use a, not a very secure password
that might be easy to guess.
So we really recommend to move
over to that password manager
and then you only have to
remember one password to that.
Super helpful.
Another tool that I
recommend people look into
is something called Security Checkup.
That's a place where you
can actually keep track
of all your online accounts and passwords,
and be notified if there is a
breach, such as a data breach,
or a phishing attempt that
got access to your password.
It'll help you keep track
of kind of how long those passwords
have been staying the same,
and remind you to update them.
So, definitely check out
Security Checkup as well.
- Super useful. Thanks so much, Grace.
- Thank you, Sal.